et g reçoit maintenant la comédienne
brigitte fossé pour paroles de prévert à
la maison de la poésie bonsoir on ça
alors bientôt 50 ans de carrière vous
rendez compte
vous êtes très bas là dedans mais vous
me rappelez marcello mastroianni oui
quand je les ai rencontrés à cannes
savais pas que j'étais arrivé avant lui
mais alors la fille du juge souter
d'ivoire souhaite une très très vieille
d'art j'étais juste derrière bientôt 40
ans de carrière
alors les actualités pour vous en ce
moment là parce que hier soir et ce soir
sur france 2 il ya une mini série qui
s'appelle passage interdit de jouer ça
avec françois dunoyer de michaël
perrotta que vous comparez à ce qu'aulas
d'ailleurs perrotta mais perdent pas et
est un lien il aime les gens ils
racontent des choses importantes sera
ton comique chose ça génial vous été une
des premières on en reparlera nous
étions une des premières vedettes disons
du cinéma à faire de la télé avec les
gens de mogador et finalement vous êtes
j'en suis très fier parce qu'en fait je
venais de finir m comme mathieu
jean-françois d'ampuis affine de michel
deville et j'étais en train de jouer au
théâtre de poche une très belle pièce de
romain weingarten l'été oui apprécié au
nez et on m'a proposé le ghana marie
l'on pense ou alors vous avez attention
je sais tout dia et enfin dans une autre
vie dans une autre vie et feu d'ailleurs
mon premier mari et finalement quand on
m'a proposé les gens de mogador lui
compris au liban fin tu vas pas faire ce
truc infâme tu vas pas faire de la
télévision
il faut que tu fasses du cinéma etc judy
m'écoute moi je suis comédienne de
théâtre de télévision et cinéma et je le
revendique est intéressé par saab ouvert
en me gardant le château s2000 et tout
ça et puis vous voyez maintenant de
depardieu en fait enfin de landas fait
depardieu en fait pendant fait que vous
étés disons une d une première enfin
c'est la première actu c'est hier soir
et ce soir sur france 2 une fois n'est
pas coutume suis désolé je fais la pub
d'une autre chaîne
alors à partir du 7 janvier jusqu'à la
mi février
vous jouez donc paroles de prévert bien
entendu avec catherine arditi à la
maison de la poésie alors séoul la
maison de la poésie parce que alors
c'est le théâtre molière passage molière
ça donne dans la rue saint-marc tu as
juste à côté de beaubourg voilà c'est
super simple l'ancien théâtre molière
quoi alors vous ayez déjà joué avec cat
la même catherine arditi en 88
ce spectacle sur scène oui dans une mise
en scène de robert fortune et c'était
pour trois jours et puis finalement
l'ambiance avoue le truc comme ça oui
j'adore travailler un mois pour une
journée et puis après on reprend et ça
devient un spectacle george sand la wii
pour une soirée au festival de grignan
et à moins boulot pour une soirée quoi
oui oui et à croquer au livre de cuisine
au creusot pour une soirée finalement on
l'a joué six mois au saint-georges à
paris et on l'a tourné donc alors les
arditi on va parler du spectacle et
arditi c'est quand même maintenant c'est
la famille les amis parce que bon café
nous fait donc ce spectacle dont on va
parler pierre arditi il ya eu un et un
font six qui a eu un épisode du beaucoup
de succès il ya deux tournées non là on
en a fait 4 4 et on va encore en avoir
deux qui vont sortir je pense dans
quatre cinq mois bon alors le spectacle
de prévert il faut bien dire aux gens
c'est pas une récitation de poésie sur
scène expliquait nous s'est mis en scène
s'est jouée
oui et puis si vous voulez on a essayé
de monter les textes tous les trois avec
robert fortune de manière à ce que ça
s'articule comme dans un spectacle comme
au théâtre et on se parle à travers les
poèmes on arrive même à m'abandonner à
s'engueuler justement jusqu'au moment où
deux anges comme dans les collages le
pré vert arrive et c'est morissette
leibovitch et maurice blanchot qui
viennent chanter une chanson est joué
les feuilles mortes se ramassent à la
pelle pour qu'on soit sage et après on
se déchaîne à nouveau et c'est très
agréable prévert parce qu'il ya
plusieurs tons comme comme vous savez il
ya un ton comique et un ton burlesque
que par moments c'est extrêmement
poétique mais toujours genre prose
jamais jamais ronronnera chiant non
c'est très cause alors très vert il un
peu en ce moment il a peu
voilà les gens pas il ya une époque où
prévert c'était en ce moment je trouve
qu'il a un peu dévalorisés non c'est
quand même le poète préféré des français
il ya une enquête qui était faite au
parisien libéré c'est quoi elle
préférait les français ceci dit pour moi
c'était la porte ouverte à la poésie
c'est à dire que quand j'allais à
l'école je ne voyais que par la poésie
ensuite je suis entré dans le monde de
la littérature puis que j'ai laissé
tomber pour le théâtre et le cinéma et
la légère oublier la poésie et puis
après j'ai été très malheureuse comme
toulouse et si prévert qui m'a ouvert la
porte
vous avez d'abord publié un recueil de
poésie ses récents ses récents nombreux
tours et puis alors dans le passé votre
père édité à boulogne-sur-mer une revue
de nos revues de poésie
mon grand-père votre grand maternelle
écrivait des poèmes
et mon père aussi écrit et écrivait des
poèmes
et mon père a fait sa demande en mariage
de ma mère en verre et mon grand-père a
répondu en l'air j'étais nourri au lait
de la poésie à votre père était prof
d'anglais dans le nord jeune fille du
nord 1 ça se voit toutefois ces niches
thierry and style alerte est venue
habiter à paris à l'âge de 9 ans est
votre premier contact avec le monde du
cinéma
c'est à cannes xavier à 4 d'une tante
qui habitait à cannes nous allier à
cannes pendant le festival est par
exemple cette maison cette maison dont
il était construite sur le jardin bâti
par le jardinier de l'empereur du
vietnam c'est là bas oui ça c'est à dire
qu'en fait c'est pour vous une
découverte du midi mais oui c'était
exotiques parce que j'étais du nord et
du pavé de l'or quand j'ai découvert les
odeurs le magnolia le romarin à toutes
ces choses extraordinaires où les figues
c'est admirable ça vous prend par le nez
moi j'aurais aimé être né j'adore les
odeurs le roman le parfum est pour moi
un des meilleurs romans qu'ils soient et
du du même coup je suis devenu moitié
méditerranéenne moitié du nord et vous
avez le château des oliviers les gens de
mogador ce qu'ils ont donné l'occasion
surtout au moment des gens de mogador
faisait bien marrer au moment du
tournage était un peu crevé le matin que
vous arriviez sur les tournages parce
que vous allez voir des petits des
petits vins régionaux
la deuxième fois ci un peu plus sages
n'ont donc pas d'ogm allemand quand je
tourne je suis toujours pressage même
quand je jouais dans le château des
oliviers où j'étais censé posséder une
ligne le paradoxe c'est que je n'ai vu
beaucoup que le dernier jour alors bon
après tout le monde sait enfin tout le
monde sait tout le monde sait que vous
avez commencé évidemment avec jeux
interdits puis c'était l'évènement
cinématographique
en fait ce qu'on sait peut d'abord c'est
qu'au départ les clément avait fait un
court métrage qui s'appelait croire en
bois un croix en feu croix en bois rond
croix en bois croix en fer voilà et que
c'est tati qui lui a dit pourquoi tu en
fais pas un long métrage et essayer d'en
faire un long métrage chercher une
petite fille qui avait 10 ans et vous
n'aviez que cinq ans et votre mère et
votre fameuse pente de cannes vous a
envoyé aux ruelles à l'hôtel roule oui
on attendait depuis si vous avez encore
très clément avait été choisi malgré
mais je dois reconnaître que c'est grâce
à sa femme bella qui est russe
parce que quand il m'a vu il m'a dit que
j'étais trop petite et elle a dit mais
rennais acier l'acier l'appétit des
troubles mais voilà je n'oublierai
jamais cette nuit en 51 dont vous étiez
une fameuse colette de jose interview de
georges de georges poujouly révélation
va vous êtes allés à de telles à venise
c'est contre 52 et scénariste aurenche
et bost
ouais pas mal apama oui on cherche des
comme ça on cherche et avait remis à
bosser avec lui mais oui il est pas con
et alors quand vous avez fait ce film la
province donc je vous interdis quand
vous êtes revenu à l'école les élèves
étaient méchants avec nancy c'est le
petit vin blanc et votre mère vous avez
quelque chose de formidable s'en
souvenait oui il m'a dit un truc
extraordinaire elle m'a dit elles sont
jalouses parce que rené clément a fait
un très beau film avec toi sont pas
jalouse de toiles sont jalouses du très
beau film sur les clément elle avait pas
tort alors passée continue un petit peu
et fait un film en italie en cinq ans
dit vous avez fait un film avec gene
kelly
la route joyeuse toujours c'est toujours
votre tante qui vous brancher sur les
coûts en fait ils s'étaient procuré
notre téléphone à tourcoing il passait
pas voir ma tante et il y avait un
critère de sélection c'était si ça se
passait pendant les vacances scolaires
c'était oui si ça se passait dans
l'école c'était non un accord mais aux
parents et c'est quand même ça
impressionne comme ça que j'ai pu voir
rome à l'âge de 7 ans j'ai fait un
disque est vrai que j'ai fait rome rome
c'est compréhensible avec louis jourdan
et viana l'isi était premier premier
film de virna lisi et ensuite
je suis allé à paris j'ai connu paris à
l'âge de 9 ans et j'ai tourné aussi un
vrai local aux eaux-vives effet indice
appelé naissance de lourdes été reçus
par le pape pie xii
oui et c'était l'abbé rené laurent tac
avait écrit les scènes de la vie de
bernadette incroyable ce sens à ses
débuts dans la vie
bah oui si c'est un fake les plutôt
normal et en 66 recoudre rumba l'on peut
dire quoi albicocco vous choisi pour le
pour le grand manan tout le monde
pensait que vous arriverez jamais à vous
séparer du personnage de paulette et là
tout le monde a pensé vous arriveriez
jamais à vous séparer du personnage du
22e gala parce que ça va coûter
mais vous savez sur ce que je fais
chaque fois que je fais un truc on dit
toujours essayé plein de choses avec la
même chose avec certains films de
truffaut mais ça n'a pas d'importance ça
veut dire que j'ai changé j'ai la chance
d'avoir la difficulté de toujours
recommencer à zéro se dire quand même
que vous marquez les personnages puisque
autant qu'il vous marque puisque on
pense que vous en sortirez jamais alors
dans le vent au môle quand même vous
avez découvert que vous étiez pas une
c'était difficile la comédie je me suis
rendu compte que j'étais nul à ce que
j'ai essayé de rechercher des sensations
de l'enfance parce que quand j'étais
petit on me disait tu pleurais je peux
tout à fait facilement
j'étais un instrument inconscient mais
là j'ai essayé de retrouver consciemment
les trucs j arrivais pas d'enjeu suis
dit il faut que j'apprenne mont laurier
vous inventer des histoires tristes pour
vous pouvez faire pleurer c'est ça oui
et puis même un moment donné
j'arrivais pas pleurer j'étais coincé
quand il faisait tellement froid ça
bloque le froid ces émotions que
albicocco m'a donné une gifle alors là
je les ai très reconnaissante pour ça
m'a fait pleurer très facilement
alors vous avez décidé d'apprendre le
métier de comédien en 67 vous entre eux
conservatoire vous trouvez que votre
synass et vous représentez vous
retournez à venise une deuxième fois tu
as aussi c'est assez exceptionnel avec m
comme mathieu est il de votre mari fou
jean françois adam alors vous avez deux
fois de suite des collisions je dirais
entre votre vie professionnelle et votre
vie privée
la première fois c'est ça ta pendant
chose interdite mais non mais non c'est
fou parce qu'elle est le film
m comme mathieu cette histoire
d'ailleurs avec ça me ferait donc ce
soir à un couple qui était sur le point
de se séparer vous à l'époque ça allait
plutôt bien encore avec votre mari puis
en 73 vous vous divorcez s'était déjà
invité des problèmes de toujours eu des
problèmes légaux c'était une histoire
vous savez j'ai le coup de foudre les
bouger sur j'étais une enfant je pensais
que je pensais que tout était possible
alors voilà ça c'était la première fois
où vous avez alors emparé de votre mari
d'aujourd'hui parce qu'il n'aime pas
qu'on parle de lui
donc on n'en parlera pas je sais pas de
qui vous parlez donc pas dire collision
entre votre vie privée et votre vie
professionnelle disons c'est ce film où
finalement qui racontait un petit peu ce
qu'elle vous arriver et puis la deuxième
chose c'est la boum cirque quand vous
jouez dans la boum vous avez les mêmes
problèmes avec votre fille marie adam
donc et comédienne qui donne et
comédienne elle aussi que à un moment
elle vous dit mais maman ce que tu es en
train de me dire on dire les dialogues
de la wii ça m'a permis de désamorcer
certains rapports très tendus et très
très autoritaire parce que en plus mon
problème c'est qu'elle a des deux ans de
moins que vick donc à 11 ans elle me
demandait déjà d'aller en boum c'était
un peu dur là vous avez été les dignes
très belles choses sur utiliserait le
mari je vous avais dit que marie cède 1
à g ii et mais oui c'est ça c'est ça
c'est julien lauray elle a eu le droit
d'être comédienne quand quand elle
aurait le bac et le lendemain du bac l
et venez vous dire j'ai trouvé mon prof
s'occupe de rien surtout étant mêle pas
et on 72 et jouer ensemble dans château
des oliviers
rapport à ces conflictuelle alors le g20
n'en parlais tout à l'heure c'est
vraiment la preuve du raison de faire
confiance à la télévision parce que ça
vous a permis de devenir une grande
actrice populaire française et puis
d'avoir cette date enfin j'ai été
reconnue à travers la télé autant 82
cinéma finalement en fait moi j'aime
tout mais c'est vrai que ce que
j'aimerais c'est toujours toujours me
balader comme ça de l'un à l'autre de la
télé au théâtre cinéma j'ai pas un
tropisme particulier pour l'un des trois
je suis au fond assez volage alors vous
avez un autre truc c'est que vous vous
seriez toujours
alors quand on vous dit ça vous dit
c'est l'orgueil qui meurent en lice
quand je traverse le chaos je
préférerais mourir que de dire ce qui ne
va pas on avait peut-être quelque chose
d'assez timide c'est assez dur
évidemment on se demande toujours quand
on vous voici au delà de votre apparence
joyeuse sereine et steria pas il n'y a
pas une brèche si c'est pas un souci
finalement votre sourire c'est pas un
peu la politesse du désespoir j'ai pas
désespérer mais j'ai des hauts et des
bas je suis assez fusée la concierge
donne mes amis à ces cyclistes se situe
dans les moments chauds en bas je vais
comme une tortue ou la chair mais je
pleure volontiers aux six ans après
agréable seulement le problème après
c'est que ça fait vraiment des très très
gros yeux donc un très belle façon
souvent c'est vous qui l'avez raconter
ses sept vietnamienne qui vient de
perdre ses enfants son mari et sa maison
vous soumet cette histoire et on lui
demande pourquoi elle sourit et elle dit
l'habitude du malheur enfin c'est pas
mon cas franchement c'est tellement on
était mal comme moi ça va donc ya pas
derrière cette apparence
souriante volontairement et toujours
souriante n'y a pas non plus à vous
cachez pas un drame existentiel profond
sanaa si elle tombait écoutez
franchement je crois que tout le monde à
un moment donné dans la vie rencontre
des épreuves et nous on est des clowns
notre eau le vôtre le mia finalement
c'est pas très loin c'est pas très loin
je crois qu'on est là un peu pour amuser
et faire rêver pas se prendre au sérieux
vd une belle chose d'ailleurs nombreux
sont ceux à linstar vous êtes très
connus vous n'êtes pas devenu une star
je vous ai dit quelque chose de très
beau sur les stages c'est qu'on termine
là dessus vous aviez une star elle comme
comme une étoile
elle donne la lumière qu'elle reçoit
c'est vrai que les étoiles sabri parce
que c'est éclairé
moi je crois que je dois beaucoup au
public et je dois beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup aux gens qui me sont fidèles et
d'une certaine manière j'ai qu'une envie
c'est de parler de se voir et à part ça
bon ben j'espère continuer parce que
vous n'êtes pas devenu ce design star au
sens médiatique du terme parce que j'ai
toujours voulu protéger votre vie privée
il ya des choses que de vous que vous
vous c'est bien quand on laisse taille
on obligé de laisser entrer les
journalistes à la maison savait que moi
je suis pour la multiplicité des
cultures
je crois que dans le mot star ce que
j'aime pas c'est que c'est exclusivement
en anglais
par contre j'adore le mot étoiles
d'abord parce que dans le mot étoiles il
ya quelque chose d'archaïque
d'ancestrales et que moi aussi je suis
derrière une étoile et je cherche comme
tout le monde
donc ce que j'aime pas dans la notion de
stars c'est qu'on a toujours
l'impression qu'on attend de nous de
dire des vérités premières est éternel
et je crois comme jacques prévert que le
plus important c'est la liberté c'est
pas avoir d'étiquette c'est de pouvoir
rire quand on a envie de rire pleurer
quand on a envie de pleurer je suis
comme je suis je suis fait ça c'est ce
que m'avait pour finir est ce que dans
le spectacle de prévert donc quitte à la
maison de la poésie avec catherine
arditi
est ce que vous vous dites le poème
parce qu'il est question de campo loin
louis de louis 3 louis iv qui parlent
pas vous faire je vais vous dire qu'il
est oublié
qu'est ce que c'est que ces gens-là qui
en s'arrêtant a 18 mai ya eu un louis 19
merci en tous les cas et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez
vous mettez un pouce bleus